des toiles à avec joseph hanna et mon
père sur scène c'est c'est inouï poids
[Musique]
chez les chedid
la musique est une affaire de famille en
1999 m sort le tube
jeudi m écrite par sa grand mère
l'écrivaine andrée chedid mes enfants et
mes petits-enfants ont tous les âges
dans les photos qui sont là quand je
vois mes enfants quand je vois je vois
tout leur visage et j'ai l'impression
que c'est un seul visage ou grand mère
un petit fils ben on peut aussi être sur
la même longueur d'onde parler la même
langue et puis arrivé à confronter nos
cultures et nos générations et en faire
quelque chose m a aussi travaillé avec
son père
l'artiste louis chedid en 2010 louis
sortait son 16e album réalisé en partie
par son fils on travaille ensemble parce
qu'on a une espèce de
moi je trouve une secouse musicale
énorme donc on s'entend très bien et en
plus de ça on est père et fils donc
alors là ça c'est la cerise sur le
gâteau chez les chedid
la musique c'est dans le sens 2009
matthieu chedid sort son quatrième album
mister mystère qui sera double disque de
platine
il collabore avec son frère joseph et sa
soeur anna eux aussi musicien on a quand
même 15 et 15 et 16 ans de différence
avec max et quand on était petits on
voyait presque puisque mathieu dans
notre quotidien que nos terres en 2015
la famille chedid parcourt la france
pour une série de concerts c'est la
première fois qu'ils sont réunis sur
scène pour arriver à trouver une sorte
d'alchimie pour que chacun ait sa place
et c'est ça c'est un peu l'image d'une
famille quoi il faut qu'on retrouve et
son rôle dans la vie votre sa place dans
la vie le dernier album de m accueille
un nouveau membre de la famille
l'artiste chante en duo avec sa fille
billie une chanson lui est d'ailleurs
dédié on n'est jamais
[Musique]
aux gens qu'on aime
annie jamais assez
qu'on les aime
je faisais
[Musique]